welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
boss I'm here with it's me I'm Whitney
hi Whitney laningham we are going to
react to the Indiana Jones in the dial
of Destiny trailer that just came out at
Brazilian Comic Con CC XP uh I I did see
at least a version of this trailer at
d23 uh last uh September but ah we love
Indiana Jones here at new rockstars we
haven't had enough opportunities to talk
about it there's been not nearly enough
opportunities to talk about it
especially with all the Star Wars going
around here that's been the most the
most Harrison Ford action we've been
we've been getting into lately right
right and uh but but lucasfilm has so
much more to offer and we have this uh
this movie's coming out uh June 30th of
2023 uh James Mangold is directing it
he's the guy who did Logan he did Ford
versus Ferrari one of the best directors
working right now uh and we're super
excited to look at this trailer uh let's
uh waste no more time hey you know as
Indy said we're figuring this out as we
as we go really so
let's dive right into it here we go
I miss the desert the Sala sala's back
I know that voice anywhere
I'm falling out of my chair right now
can we write I love you on our eyelids
yeah can we both just like wait where's
the pen
she had to walk around all day with that
on her eyelids good for her that's
called committing to it everyone fell in
love with her that day you mean is that
for me are you talking to me
there he is not I love he kept keeps a
hat he does Indy I don't believe in
magic
you don't believe in magic why okay
after everything you've seen that
doesn't make sense the d18 looks so good
right I'm not crazy no that is
that's the best we've ever seen
a horse
[Music]
hard to believe
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God yes yes little cart little
cart chain leave this poor old man alone
he's been throwing up he wants to retire
he's a professor
there's so much whip action in this
trailer who is this man I'm her
Godfather
back
he knows he knows because that's like
Indie face I've ever seen classic that
was so much
[Music]
I mean this is like class that's got to
be a callback to Raiders right the guy
with the sword
just like bro nobody has time for this
he's now he's on the other side of it
this is like ah like I look I I don't
know how you feel about this Whitney
every time when like a trailer comes out
my first reaction is never to like
scrutinize the VFX I'm just like like
overwhelmed by the magic of it and uh I
don't know I don't believe in magic
though so I don't know how people can
react to a trailer right away and be
like the BFF looks terrible like I never
that's never my burst reaction it's
always like my second or third viewing
of it oh yeah I know I have to watch it
a few times before I hate something
[Laughter]
to me this this just looks great I mean
James mangled seems to have such a good
take on it uh a quick uh rundown of what
we know about this this is gonna be set
in the year 1969 American archaeologist
adventure Indiana Jones uh it's gonna be
in the backdrop of the Space Race so um
he started to feel doubts about the US
government
um recruited former World War II enemies
desperation to beat the Soviet Union
right so that was the big deal during
the Cold War we were both in this race
to get to the moon first
um uh Phoebe Waller Bridge playing his
goddaughter Helena uh accompanying him
on this journey and the villain is going
to be a vole or voler a NASA member
ex-nazi involved with it so USU fans
this is like projects Nazis on the moon
that is just the perfect Indiana Jones
five I'm sorry what's better than Nazis
on the moon
I mean I mentioned uh Arnhem Zola right
and Toby Jones himself is going to be in
this movie playing basil but that's a
similar thing right they're your
recruiting former uh uh Nazis into the
US government to uh help with things
like the Space Race to beat uh the
Soviets um so yeah we're gonna we're
probably gonna go to the Moon we don't
really see that in this trailer though
right no I don't I I don't see Nazis on
the moon I just believe that Indiana
Jones could kick Nazi's ass on the moon
if he wanted to
this video is brought to you by the
ridge if you are a nerd you know how
important rings are from Middle Earth to
the MCU and all Realms in between the
right ring on your finger can really
make or break your day and the folks at
the ridge know that and that's why they
are making Rings behold
my trash
rings from the ridge come in a variety
of Premium materials including carbon
fiber tungsten carbide 24 karat gold and
titanium and each band comes with a dual
band silicone ring for when you want to
be comfortable or casual the ring has an
outer beveled Edge for on hand comfort
and an inner convex shape for a
comfortable no pinch fit hey and if
you're the type who's worried about
wearing a ring because you don't want to
lose it well the ridge offers lost and
resizing protection whether you lose
your ring or lose 20 pounds each
purchase comes with the option of two
future exchanges for the same ring in
the same or different size head to
ridge.com new rockstars and right now
you can save up to 40 through December
22nd okay so uh Whitney tell me about
your like experience with the Indiana
Jones franchise oh man it's just my my
favorite ever I have been the biggest
Indiana Jones fan since I was a little
kid actually a fun a fun game that my
younger my little god brother and I used
to play growing up is he would be
Indiana Jones and I would be Princess
Leia and so we had this mashup of just
like Harrison Ford Carrie Fisher
um and that was obviously my favorite
game to play as a child uh I am a
die-hard Last Crusade fan as far as the
original trilogy goes that is fine I
mean it's a good one favorite of all
time
um actually really more than Raiders
yeah I like it more than Raiders I
really do and I know that that's a
controversial take but I like it I
really I love the Last Crusade
um that's also why I'm like oh you don't
believe in magic you watched a guy's
face melt dude what do you mean that was
that was some crazy [ __ ]
um but yeah I I just I love this
franchise I love you know young River
Phoenix on the train I saw so many
things in this trailer that like
reminded me of moments in the Last
Crusade just because that's the one
that's always on my mind but definitely
him running across the train was
absolutely like like exactly the open
owner of Last Crusade and then
um also there there seemed to be a part
where they were dunking in water and
that totally reminded me of the
underwater like catacomb and Graves that
they had yeah in Venice and like just
seeing all of that stuff oh I'm just so
excited to see like little things
brought back that are gonna be told in
totally new ways yeah
um I uh I just watched Raiders like last
weekend just like uh uh when my wife was
um I think out with friends or we just
weren't uh I don't know where we were
but we watch Raiders because I will
always put on Raiders
um and uh I I grew up with this
franchise I mean some of my earliest
memories are watching whatever recording
we had of Temple of Doom on VHS oh
absolutely and just falling in love with
Indy in Short Round And the fact that
like uh kihoi Quan has had a career
comeback is like my favorite thing to
happen ever it's the best
um and I know at d23 uh and Harrison
Ford ran into each other backstage and
had that hug and I just love the story
that like Harrison Ford like recognized
him right away and was like get over
here like
I love that and I was on my earliest
nerds also going to the Indiana Jones
stunt show at what was then MGM now it's
Hollywood Studios yeah I love that show
so much and my dad got brought in to be
a volunteer and uh they just had him be
the guy who like helps up the stunt man
who gets uh punched right right yeah so
like that's uh I've I've grown up with
Indiana Jones I I love it so much and
yeah I would uh I had this uh this weird
leather fringe coat that I wore as a kid
and I would wear it on that was like my
Indiana Jones uh coat that it was a kid
I'm gonna try to find a photo maybe we
can get it you have to I I definitely
have a photo of me dressed as Indiana
Jones for Halloween one year too so
um so I believe uh my rule with Indiana
Jones movies is the best ones have not
seasoned them right yeah and if they
don't have Nazis in them it's just not
as good it's the fact that they knew
they haven't ex-nazi here and the fact
that we're gonna flash back to mads
Mickelson as a as uh baller or volay
um to their Nazi days and the Indiana
Jones will always have that mistrust of
him you know and I love in the shot we
de-aged him uh and he's wearing the Nazi
uniform so it's going to be some Mission
maybe something specifically from Last
Crusade uh because it looks like it's
some old uh Castle right there's like a
roaring fireplace in the background uh
maybe he's like I never I could never
trust a Nazi which you shouldn't if
someone was once a Nazi in their lives
they're always a Nazi I don't care Nazi
don't trust them don't bone Menace with
them just don't I'm looking at this
parade right now Whitney and I'm trying
to figure out where this is my instant
goes to like it's a it's a v-day parade
but no this is like in the modern era uh
it's like uh where exactly is this
um where this ticker tape is is
billowing down it's like there's like a
Miss America with a sash on and another
car who's uh reacting to all this I mean
to me when I think Harrison Ford in a
crowded parade I think the future right
I think like Harrison Ford is like he
knows how to run on top of a train he
knows how to like um uh conduct a chase
scene through a parade dude that man can
do anything and all things and I love a
good Harrison Ford running through a
crowd scene it's it's always the best
it's never not the best
um you know I I take it back I said we
don't see any space shots but it looks
like at about 109 in the trailer it
looks like people are either underwater
or in space in a space shuttle oh I'm
looking at some kind of water but is it
I mean they're looking at some kind of
some Rift through Dimensions right
doesn't that look like we're gonna go
into the cosmos what do we think the
dialogue that does look a little uh a
little a little Millennium Falcon
cockpit Vibes in that doesn't matter
yeah dial of Destiny is dial when I
think of dial I think of like a compass
style I think of some kind of I was
thinking about like an old sundial
the fact that we're going to go to space
are we gonna touch back with Crystal
Skull and do with uh aliens and
extraterrestrials I mean uh you know
Crystal Skull is still Indiana Jones
Cannon yeah we do still live in a world
where aliens help build the uh the
pyramid the Mayan pyramids or the
Mesoamerican pyramids yeah I mean and
that's that's like what's interesting
too is that obviously Indiana Jones 5
kind of did perfectly set this or sorry
Indiana Jones four This is Indiana Jones
Indiana Jones 4 did kind of perfectly
set this up in a way I mean love it or
hate it man I know I know that there's a
lot of flaws within Kingdom of the
crystal skulls but I mean having the the
aliens to lead into this and also just
just like the way that Indiana Jones
right it takes place during the past
obviously and each movie kind of focuses
on Central fears of that time period and
so the fact that like they did focus on
aliens in four it it worked with the
time the 1950s big big alien scare big
Mars Attacks kind of moment and so now
that we are doing the Space Race it kind
of does it just makes sense I don't know
even even if Kingdom of the crystal
skulls isn't your favorite movie you
gotta admit this is kind of cool it's
kind of a cool lead-in yeah I won't be
um bummed if if we deal with aliens here
um I've I'm gonna find it more
interesting if we go into like alternate
Dimensions I don't want to see what's on
the other side of that Dimension because
what's hard about aliens is like what I
loved about the earlier Indiana Jones
films from the 80s is they all
um their their mysticism was all
grounded in faith yeah uh that like we
learned of the existence of God and it's
just hard to say we live in a universe
where there is an Old Testament God
who's going to melt Nazi faces but also
a universe where there are aliens and
it's kind of hard to know the the
balance of power and the power hierarchy
of that universe so if uh if this movie
could do a true throwback and whatever
the mysticism is it's grounded in faith
somehow especially for battling Nazis
who were you know uh if you look at I I
try not to spend too much time reading
up on what Nazis really believed because
that's that could be a scary rap at all
don't either I went to history class
though so I I think I know I know from
like history but my fear I'm listening
to that podcast that from Jordan peels
production company yes I'm listening to
Monkey pop Productions quiet power loud
podcast story Tracy let's replace this
like Alex Jones type figure who is like
haunted by this curse of like the rabbit
hole curse where you can be led to these
conspiracy type thinking uh so I have
now learned to just avoid certain
corners of the internet because who
knows what that will lead you and uh and
yeah I think the Nazis were like you
know obviously there's anti-christian
values in the way they treat other human
beings ultimately I just loved how God
punched the Nazis
Nazis man Indiana Jones makes being a
Christian cool yes so uh I I hope that
this movie brings us back to that like I
I would love if the mysticism of this
movie could be something grounded in
fate I don't think that the mysticism
should be aliens again for the record
what to clarify what I was trying to say
was like I that movie sucked but at
least now there's a little tie-in
between them so that you can be like
okay but no I don't want aliens to be
running the show in this movie
whatsoever please don't I want to say
another little sweet something about uh
the director of this film directing
Logan I think that for Indiana Jones 5
this is kind of perfect because James is
so good and is proven to be good at
writing like the heroes swan song of
films he sent off Logan so beautifully
we all know that Harrison Ford is
unfortunately getting old we also all
know that he doesn't want to do these
goddamn franchises and I think he loves
he loves Indiana Jones a lot more than
he loved Star Wars to be fair but they
killed him off in Star Wars too the
character eventually has to retire in
some capacity even if if he doesn't die
in this movie let's just say he just
retires or you know whatever the case
passes the Baton down to the Phoebe
Waller bridge that would be great too
but I think that
if this does turn out to be some sort of
farewell to Indiana Jones there's no
better director like if we got the
feeling and the emotion and the action
of Logan for the Indiana Jones character
in its own way that would be so cool I I
am really looking forward to seeing what
this director does with it hey you know
uh my opinion Whitney is that they
better not kill off this old man I don't
want him to die okay I never want him to
die I'm just saying
I hear what you're saying and I agree
with you I think James mingled is so
good at that and I thank Harrison Ford
you're right he uh I think he might
retire from acting pretty soon
um so what I want for him is not his
character to die but to ride off into
the sunset and after this I want a short
round movie that's what I want too yes
yeah my dream pitch for an Indiana Jones
sequel is Like Short Round has to put
back everything from old ruins that uh
the Indiana Jones or other explorers
have taken Short Round has to put it all
back yeah
Museum thing it's like no it doesn't
belong to the museum it belongs in the
Earth
right right and I think the fact that uh
kihu Kwan is having this like career
Resurgence
perfect it would be so perfect I've been
thinking about this the entire time yes
I'm in full support of this right well
let's do this I'm so excited for this
movie to come out
um thank you so much for watching this
everybody let us know in the comments
below what your thoughts and theories
are about what exactly the dial of
Destiny is and whether you want aliens
or God or just other dimensions that
have no other religious affiliation to
be the mystery of this movie uh be sure
to uh follow Whitney at Whitney puppy at
Whitney puppy on social media you can
follow me at EA boss on all social media
follow new rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars uh wherever uh we are and you
can uh if you're in the LA area you can
find us at La Comic Con this Sunday
December 4th uh where we'll be doing a
panel we'd love to hang out with you
meet in person but we'll see you next
time everybody bye
[Music]
thank you